my ice cream like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese like a dude is hurt ain't
dance night dance Steven I just got
dance oh my god
[Music]
hey guys hey welcome to the worst fire
team ever podcast episode one I'm Craig
Steve Frank
welcome to the worst fire team ever
podcast number one I'm Craig Steve cope
Frank no I should be Griffin it was your
birthday I have like this is that what
it is you're just insane hi welcome to
the worst fire team ever podcast I'm
Steve Craig Eric Franke so anyway um so
we're here to talk about gaming destiny
so first off let's talk about your
birthday
it was fine let me it was a surprise
party yeah okay so I get there sorry I
didn't make it Frank said hey Steve I'm
gonna take you to the gun range on your
birthday as a surprise so I was planning
to go to the gun range and so yesterday
I was with him in him and they drove me
well first time we had to wake you up to
get you out of the house okay that's why
we didn't go through and that's why we
didn't go shooting early this Steve
didn't show up so you were gonna go
shoot that was a real thing right yeah
so at 3 3 o'clock go knock on the door
you're in your underwear yeah like yeah
yeah and then you go I'll be there in 15
minutes 45 minutes later why this is not
destiny I just want you sorry go to the
part where we're getting to know us okay
go to the part where we talk about web
okay we get to the house of blue that we
missed so much of the story in the
backyard was you know that in play I was
like it the it trailer there is a person
with a yellow rain jacket hold a red
balloon in the backyard of my neighbors
and were you scared
well what I thought was funny about the
whole deal was Steve thought this was
real and he acted as if okay coax the
fighter let him go that's like
paranormal but I forgot to tell cope
that we were doing the it surprise how
do you decide are you gonna do a scary
movie so rides for someone's birthday
this wasn't me this was his girl Michael
his girlfriend decided she cuz Steve
loves it he's like I've been watching
the trailer a lot right anyway what the
question is yeah she looks okay so you
saw this trailer a few times and then
from that she decided to do a surprise
party you've seen the new trailer where
the thing is coming out
[Music]
[Applause]
so like you what did you think when you
saw her I was scared
dude you didn't want to come outside but
knew but the thing was everybody was
waiting on the side of the building I I
didn't okay with me they let me take
over here so at what point did you get
surprised you saw that there's all those
freaky because my friends oh my girl
turn I'm like oh it's my girlfriend no
and then that's it can we go on to
destiny now so now you're scared of her
now alright so going to destiny yeah
don't you said it well you wrote did you
wrote this
I know but once how did we all meet and
play together well so how did we start
you started with it started over here
it's not with you right Steve's brother
like you know you know we didn't really
introduce ourselves properly okay this
is Steve Lee you know famously brother
of Bobby Lee Frankie OH
over here winner Erich Koch UFC fighter
extraordinaire trying out pros bum Craig
so that's what we do and so Bobby and I
started playing you know and then we
just got bored cuz cuz it's not that we
got bored
it's just that destiny is set up where
you have to play with people yeah right
you know yeah it's the good and bad of
it so the good of it is like you know
you're this forcing you to like find
people to play with but sometimes but
Bobby's such a weird dude he didn't want
to play with people that we didn't know
Yeah right like a year and I have to end
up playing with you guys
yeah so right I had to like it was like
remember Bobby at the store we were
talking about that sounds like yeah I
picked it up he was like do you play I
was like I used to and he's like no
you're gonna play yeah you need to get
to this light level and so what he did
was like but then when we were playing
the first thing you did he knew he can
get Steve yeah he was like I'm gonna get
to you like set you up oh yeah and then
those were the fun times like those are
the closing here yeah golden times were
like me Bobby is T play until 6:00 a.m.
and the reason of elders elders and
they're like fighting and rage quit II
thought Ron you let yelling at each
other but then like the the the thrill
of like finally completing it it was the
best and it just became a routine it
became like the way destiny set up you
had this like weekly thing where you
like alright you have to do your dailies
and you had to do the weekly whatever is
part of your weekly schedule yeah it's
like a schedule didn't like Bobby would
come on it'd be like I got to do a 32 -
you got something when you rank up
member ewie you know you did all the
math because remember you there's a
point system yeah you reach 5,000 or
15,000 points that was later how it is
now you got a row you got a weapon or
like you always got something good yeah
you know Vic from verax yes so was that
where except the ring though when it
came out it was my first came out yeah
those were the those were fun yes no no
no before House of wolves it was when it
was more important no no no the the hive
had a sword guy oh the hot yeah crota
on the Cosmodrome member until the taken
king right so we had something we was
like the wolves by that point yeah I
came on house of wolves cuz you guys
were looking you're like we need another
one
you gotta get on you gotta get on so I
have it on play wait wait since you said
house wolves dude I missed that
I miss you know the falling coming or do
you guys like to fall in coming in you
randomly or like the taken I really
should take I think they should have had
like they are they shouldn't have got
rid of any of it I think that hi she
still should come yeah yeah house of
wolves still should come and then they
take a [ __ ] show up I think it should be
all this there's a point we're like on
certain maps you would have the fall and
the take and then you'd see them all
fight oh that was cool yeah and then a
like a fall and like Walker would drop
usually ah [ __ ] yeah because it's
chaotic it was hard at first like every
time they updated it the stuff was
harder and then I got easier that was
kind of the other thing you think that
if you go let's just go through the
origin and like the like the whole thing
with destiny like the thing that I love
about it is is always evolving because I
remember when it first heart happened
ahead people would be shooting in the
caves
it's like isn't it crazy how people find
out how to cheat like yes okay so it'll
be like you're on the Cosmodrome and
there's like you know six people stand
in front of a cave shooting into a cave
so they fixed that and then in the first
part cuz they'd like you know go for
those stupid things you needed all that
stuff you had to like you know like that
all the cool yeah you had to like
harvest all this stuff yeah it would
take hours
well that's the thing too is like you
guys weren't like all the stuff you guys
had collected became useless yeah Oh cuz
remember how those a third like Oh even
before that cuz remember in the
beginning like a hunter had a specific
thing in there I forgot what that stuff
was called
and they had and they had different what
do you call it a currency yeah then they
kept changing into changing yeah yeah
there was like three different
currencies yeah they killed him it was
it was well then you had to go like
around you
no no let me go back to we top all the
Wolves again yeah we I'm one thing that
like I got a panic attack remember at
the end you remember like the treasure
chest we don't like it would be like oh
just pop up here I have to know you'd
like a driver jumps in you would go yeah
ours I know you and Bob law that's one
thing I couldn't stand right I don't
like mining I hated see I feel I was so
happy when you can buy stuff I feel like
the first I can tell because they
changed it they changed it like three
times with Howell
yeah but I feel like you as a giant like
I feel like the game in itself is a
giant like beta I feel like they fit
right I think they're doing a lot I like
good things in the next one you know
we'll get to that way well I'm just
saying like some movie on the PBE side I
think it's gonna be better in not as
monotonous yeah so we made a point where
I was like destiny one was like it was
like a theme park you go to Disneyland
is like hero the rides and even the
patrols still seemed very like set in
their ways like a beacon patrol yeah so
you never really felt as free like to
Rome as was right was its to felt like a
theme park no I thought it was very open
world it's just that we just knew the
world after playing the game so long I
know every inch of every unit of Venus
every well yeah yeah I would see you and
I would just join your fireteam put on
you know like where he's hidden that to
you do that all the time is offline all
the time when they just go on to your
part you know you're like when there's
ten other people and I know don't know
and but let's leave you us it's even us
like Coke will be like I know Steve's on
you know like we know you're all you
don't really know yeah I'll send them
invites just to like but then you always
get angry you're like why are you guys
not on I'm like you're not on I went on
but I can't see you cuz you're invisible
that's something going on with the
system though there's like a glitch like
you know how you can that's not a thing
it's not just yes I think it's something
with the Xbox were you like you you try
to you try to join somebody's fired to
him and you can't yeah there was a thing
with Bobby like remember Steve would be
like I'd have to invite you the fire
team leader was yeah but by getting back
to it though those days raining the
beginning days but then what we then we
were like we want to play other parts of
the game so then one of the things that
was like fun to do was like to try to do
the raid and then one thing about the
destiny is like you need six people you
know you have to have sets when we start
to build it and that's when we were like
yeah we got to get other people to play
and that's why we got everybody in so
you bug me for a while because I hadn't
on ps4 and I didn't like it cuz I had no
friends on ps4 so I was like I never
played there and then you're like hey
you got it you got to get on it you got
to get on and by the way when we first
started well at least I could speak
about on my own I never played PvP
that's yeah that's right and I loved
crucible and I didn't we didn't I
started playing trials and told wait
that was me well that was also me and
Steve like I started to be like we got a
play I got it into it cuz of you I know
and you get into that we loved and hated
me over but so so but you guys have met
coke what happened was and all explained
yeah because it's weird is this so girl
it's just a long world I follow
I followed Griffon because I'm a big
workaholics ain't right so like I
already followed Griffin I saw him tweet
bungees about I was like oh [ __ ] you
know I dropped a line I was like [ __ ]
man you ever want to play hit me up and
he ended up following me and you know we
never talked but he ended up following
me and then we use the the app because
in the app you can yeah yeah because I
don't know so there was a rape party I
wanted to do I think it was the orange
it was the aurochs right so like we were
doing that so we were playing for a good
two three hours they were talking about
comedy and I yeah I wasn't thinking
anything I mean I was just doing the
rain no no because he would said and
then you were talking about UFC fighting
because what your name is right right
and I and I asked I said well what is
your thing yeah I look him up online I
see he's like Montez sound like oh no
[ __ ] but yeah I was literally talking to
him talking for hours but that's the
thing about look one of the things we're
gonna talk about destiny for a second is
one of the things I hate and love is
that you know like I said you have to
you have to add people right so you have
to have you want to raid you got to have
six people and then not all of us have
six people that play this game so you
have to go on five people but then what
I don't like is once you get to know
these people like we became a group then
it becomes like oh what we want to go do
strikes all yeah but there's four of us
on yeah you know and that's how Craig
and Frank started fighting go like
that's like how that would happen so
then that's what sucks about it yeah
yeah that's the thing I don't like about
destiny is that like now you make us get
six people we have six and now we came
to play together right like the patrols
where it was just three people that
should should be able to you should be
able to fill up the whole server because
like when you look on the thing 16
people can be there you should be able
to put actually as many people as you
want on beyond patrolling because it's
like here's our big group and
all go to the quarter Oryx let's all go
to the Archon force together be like wow
where it's like they got huge bosses
like 200 should be able to add people I
think that server issues though I think
like that's an issue on just a technical
level because even just us connecting
some of the times there were so many
times where just yeah well oh yeah and
crank out like a worst I did yeah I
upgraded much 10 years to yeah but not
as bad as Frank Franklin Kentucky Fried
Chicken so then we got everybody finally
got together we all got the team
together and then then the rains wall I
guess you have another friend - what
happened to your other friend Gavin yet
another friend that was on there he sold
his xbox I can't do this my life oh yeah
that was your buddy one of your friends
yes yes I've never played a game as much
as I play the same game really should
just all be about like how we started
playing yeah
whatever I remember I remember doing it
anyway what we dislike about destiny
it's just tempting
I remember when Bobby came up he was
like you got to play destiny I went out
the next day and bought everything and
the cool thing was I had played destiny
when it was on 360 so it actually
transferred all of my characters the
Xbox one and that blew my mind yeah this
is the first time I've ever played a
game where like you do a mission right
and then it's like you're to do you do
it again and again and the guy was like
I'm doing the same thing again yeah I
met him he's a great actor but like
because they had this kind of casino
thing that's why we all the way the
exotic scoping in it's gold it's not
even just that it's just the whole idea
that you play the same thing and you get
different results different roles and
all that and so then you're like looking
at I don't even think I don't think it's
like gambling I don't even think you
even able to like really explore
everything in destiny like I don't think
like you you know I mean right there so
far someone was saying I think it was
like it was actually like a TV producer
who played it and he was like in a show
he made I made a joke about how he still
hasn't gotten this gun and he'd played
destiny for like three years and it's
like there's certain people like there's
certain guns that I still haven't even
got exotic yeah well you go to the
exotic the armor this vidiian aspects i
just got it like a couple months ago and
it's been out most of you don't have a
sword no I don't have
I would always get the guns after they
nerfed them oh yeah so like you would
have unit grass oh you got a clever draw
I never got never got when I got it it
was like the week after they made it use
you never got to talk about his family
he was good with it dude you had I think
he had that stability yeah and it had a
rangefinder
it had heat showerhead secret head
seeker and also the same ability when
you get when you hit him in the chest or
when you it's that seeker but then he
had high Cal rounds on it that's why you
destroyed no one could beat you trying
to beat you but this a nobody I mean
you're the only person here that yeah
speaking of guns though that they had
this brilliant with me and I was super
[ __ ] salty about it before they did
the treasure keys or whatever oh yeah
like get loot at the end right oh yeah
the specific so Oh taking mine for the
imago the best one that's my favorite
hand cannon right the VEX the next one
the VEX one I'm not dying - yeah so but
right before that update came out for
that chest like the chest keys the loop
would just drop from killing the boss
yep it was random so I remember was a
nightfall and the nightfall I was doing
I was farming if there's a way to farm
it back remember you'd stand up on that
brick yeah I think in there and snipe
you
you'd kill them but why you killed him
you'd kill yourself - yeah but the
rocket launches the loot stays with it
and then you have to do it over and over
so you don't have to go through the
whole mission so I people like you why
they had to nerf bed but I wanted I
wanted a God walk right this
[ __ ] comes in one game one game
it drops a god rule and I was so good I
was doing us doing it for hours and
courage like oh I got one is it good and
he puts it on and I'm just like that's
the thing that's the thing it kind of
punishes you cause like I'm not good
with hand camp I swear you know that
rifle I'm definitely the worst even
worse than that you go with the
Montecarlo I'll give you that shoulder
show what they did a shoulder charge
it's like six pages of soda
would be running and then seeing like
Craig go to shoulder charge of dude and
it was like when they nerfed it so the
distance was like shoulder charge and
stop right in front of the guy and talk
about you you're interesting he always
but he only uses a Titan machiners
always all-white no black it uses like
one led the Monte Carlo or something it
actually does well I mean when I first I
was using shotguns cuz I used to love
the shotgun but you said they make em
too but that's the thing everything I
used once like the rattle with Frank
they deserved yeah so what else do they
nerve but that's the thing I don't like
about the game is something I like it
just like so when everybody was using
the clever dragon then they then you
never saw it again
yeah but literally that God that gun was
gone yes and I don't like that I did not
I didn't like that I'm like a baby like
you know change the meadow all the time
right yeah yeah but these little things
they kept adding to the game and taking
away from it which also makes it like
one of the most it's probably one of the
greatest games ever yeah just because of
just because like you know that there's
places you can go on if we turn the game
on right now there's places you can go
that you don't even you're like oh yeah
I forgot about Mars back you know and
then you like do those missions like so
you know it's like the the every time
they changed something I think they take
away from the game sometimes you know
it's like remember when the daily was
important and then they became a thing
where you can I fall not deny for yes
you want that back we're like if you do
the daily doing the night ball every
week was no I remember how hard it was
at first because very hard because if
you died you got sent to the beginning
oh yeah
so what feels so cool because I remember
the first night ball I did I felt like a
boss cuz we tried it so many times it's
the kind of game that you literally
would play for our hour with no six
hours success it was one night we played
and a hammer if it was prison of elders
or like so much everything is you me and
Bobby we just couldn't do it
which one was like who's the boss I just
remember it was like 6:00 in the morning
and I was like I gotta you know what is
this it's okay it depends on it depends
on what burn and all the other things
they put on like if you're playing
alright like whatever knife all is okay
like if you're playing bond Brothers is
solar and it's solar fusion always
killed me when someone was like fusion
you need to kill it no but know when you
do boy like boy it's always hard to kill
people on missions like well then one
with that I got that's a new one though
yeah I'm just talking about I'm talking
about the ones from back in the day yeah
like just the the early early the early
ones like that the Fallen one where you
have to go kill the tank there's like a
three part thing and that one was so
hard with the big idea and we always do
guys that one was doing a knife false
epics prime was super hard well also
light level light level was such a [ __ ]
even in the beginning he had a grind do
you had to grind and if you were low
light you couldn't kill anything and
they done they didn't like it in the
early game they didn't just hand out
like highlight gear you know and I think
it became a problem because people like
that couldn't do the raids like remember
you had to do the raid to get the for
whatever that's what we started doing
brother
yeah yeah now quota became fun like when
we got everybody in you started we would
do CRO to every time every week that's
what we started doing you could actually
do items three things my chest my head
and my legs you can just take your
warlock character and then put it in
your ball and then just infuse that into
your but it was definitely fun I mean
when we get the group together was fun
there's fun yeah and then but then
there's definite times when it's not I
will table that for the next well I mean
I just feel like there's a lot of like
things about destiny that gets games
within games within games because you
know and then they add this like you
know that when they add two burns or
when they add like oh this this
particular mission you have to do to get
this particular thing even though it's
the same thing you've done a thousand
times and they keep you keep making you
do it and do it and do it so like even
when like even when I'm playing the
crucible there was a time when I started
to play that and I was like oh this
could be a game this could be just the
game like there could be a game called
destiny crucible and it's just that and
it would be a worthwhile game yeah so
you have this start when did you start
crucible because I did I start lately I
mean a walk by chefs you know at the
bottom I know should be okay I would
just like to walk by I'm like no I just
don't I just tried it I just went and it
just started to do it it's like it
there's let's say this destiny is one of
the most infuriating game I've ever it's
just infuriating like you're not because
like no matter what you do for me
personally I don't care what I do I
can't get any better at certain things
me too but there are times though like
when I'm not playing like for some
buddies I'm not play with you people
yeah we're on the same team kill any
Barney to but then I want playing by
myself and get 20 kills let's go in like
75 kills me I'm
my TV Internet oh my I know certain
skill sets right like people know how to
do that shade step roll right into a
shotgun to your gut or they know how to
jump up with a palindrome and I don't
know how to do that you know say like I
don't know how to do that [ __ ] like that
they find their success but to know they
made a game that so it really is so
advanced that they can't fix it but they
keep trying to fix it and make their
there's so many more yes
could they go like okay let's make
shotguns are too heavy so we'll take
that away and then like oh our rifles
are now and then they uh let's try to do
that and then just can't do it
there's no but there is no balancing it
because these kids out here these people
out here are gonna find out how to play
well with whatever it is and they're
gonna exploit it and then once he
exploited they're like well we have to
change this now yeah
remember sidearms they no one use I
don't know but now all of a sudden
wormwood you need a wormwood yeah but it
used to be not that like nobody knows
that thing didn't tell anyone how to do
them you had figure it out online the
first [ __ ] when the Kings ball dropped
it took what 18 hours for the first team
to finish it yeah and then it took me
long to find all the secret chess but
that's that's so crazy to me cuz like
even like that's still quick yeah that's
quick yeah for like not knowing like any
minute
right cuz because for people that don't
know when you play the raid it's like
you have to do certain steps right like
you can't just go out there and shoot
everything it's like it's like it's like
a puzzle yeah
just imagine how hard it was to do
sisters not know where everything has
them and figure that all there is
they're worse YouTube yeah almost nobody
would complete it yeah you're not to
call it I know what I'm saying like
hotline
how do I jump yeah yeah but you know
like yeah I mean it's in stings for like
how many like there's about this is like
we all have
I've never did only way we've ever
completed together is crota I thought
yeah that's the only one I have never I
never not together the read the new the
new the new that we've done vault or not
never completed but I'm saying before
they check this out we never even did
prison of elders 35 you're right but we
never did it for you pudding like scoffs
we never we never do it into we're until
the next thing came out and we were like
so powerful that we could kill them
honestly you're right we never the
hardest [ __ ] bosses but that's where
you get infected and you're like do you
have it and you have is infuriating okay
remember in this I know the thing about
school laughs that was hilarious was
like with like normally on a boss right
normally on prison builders is five
rounds yeah okay I think it's five
rounds of prison of elders right this so
Bobby you me and Steve we were doing
that school loss we get to the fifth
round and we pass it and we're like
there's a six round seven hours Tom like
your peers it and you have to run and
then you have you have to count down
from ten seconds like a give it your
friend every time and every time the
kids did these kids on inning like you
said on the internet every time they
figure out how to kill something fast by
the time we get to it it's been nervous
yeah because because they had that thing
where we all have a Gjallarhorn steve
was mister look at videos the king of
like what's the best weapon that youtube
says but the thing is a good time the
next day he would text me and call me
like i just looked at this video and
they said the PDX is the bet you gotta
go get it and how many times you tell me
like a hundred times you gotta get
you gotta get a bit the vendor let me
get and the PDX PDX is great because you
call the gunsmith right you can either
get it as a drop it's just like the
Hawks it's you know for us it was it
could work I love you I love the Hawks
well one of the things I like about the
game too is that you know you have these
three characters yeah right you know
Titan hunter and warlock and then you
can pick you can like sometimes you
start playing with one for like you know
extended period of time
there you go let me go let me switch
over to this other one and then the
games I completely different yeah every
single time the game is different you
know if you're playing with a warlock
the things you could do with a warlock
and then even with so there's basically
nine characters you could play with yeah
yeah you know because in the subclass
yeah oh yeah so then that makes it by
you so let's say let's say Maine what's
everybody's man what everyone's main
character you know mine Steve no mine
yeah mine is the sticky I'm a sunsinger
ya know the no hunter does a hunger no
that's a warlock you have the shadows
yes
shut up shot yeah but that's avoid
something that's a boy yeah I like the
warlock - yeah yeah yeah I thought solar
grenades going longer TP over here yeah
I was all about tripmines you cover the
whole
that's his or you knew like we're on the
water throwing cuz cuz you're one they
stuck yeah they were lucky it would
stick you it would signal a person
what's awesome about it it's like a
fusion grenade
yeah it's the hardest-hitting grenade
though yeah so like when it so that way
you could stick somebody with the super
and it would kill him yeah oh alright
and when it had no aim assist yeah so
like it wouldn't like you you would end
with literally within literally half day
item and the best part was if there was
another person I had a triple kill in
trials one time I stuck one and both his
teammates were like you know strafing in
and out to shoot me they all wind up on
cars buying guns yeah you're tossing the
whole time yeah that's annoying for our
group is the fact that we got together
number 6 me no read number 6 plug in
what you know Stevie B's got stuff you
have to play yeah you're weird episode
do you wanna play anything
yes TV show like youtube.com slash DB we
be even edit to slash HTTP semi colon
slash slash
or it's like you're fighting you yeah I
mean we don't know yeah when you fight
again remember it'll be sometime
December I'm looking at either two dates
but I want either Vegas or Winnipeg so
I'm hoping mangas though I'm undefeated
fireteam don't know officially go
backstage and okay first rate because
they got the Commission in any drug test
and so but I can't be the corner guy but
yeah sometime in December so that'll be
my next one and you're on Twitter I'm on
Twitter new Brito for is my tag or
Instagram
cokehead UFC well I think and then Frank
comedy attacked Frank Sioux County on
Twitter Frank Castillo Denver Colorado
will be there the 27th through the 29th
then I'll be in Washington DC v so
that's he Frankie just just go to Eric
Griffin calm with the KA Rik Griffin
calm and then you'll see my dates and
stuff okay you know and I'm at Eric
riffing on everything
yeah is that a tattoo of Bobby alright
guys well first episode thank you guys
for joining
[Music]
[Applause]